on the beaches where the balance of war
shifted
where allied forces began their
operation to liberate europe
and thousands of british men and women
fell 77 years on
they are remembered despite
having to watch via satellite link this
in no way obscures the enormous regard
and admiration
in which we hold our veterans there's
been a long wait for this memorial
the first to honour the 22 442
who lost their lives under british
command here we are
uh this is my father's name yeah
it's mormon yeah yeah yeah they called
him pygmy in the army
among them michael's father lieutenant
colonel desmond smallmanchu
when you saw his name what how did that
feel
so thrilled really and proud to think
that his name will be here
ever actually on his grave it's marked
they like the stars
will shine forever and i think that
phrases
can be so well applied to this place
they received a direct hit from a
german mortar shell and so the the jeep
blew up and they were killed immediately
and that was that was it that was the
end
and how old were you i was nine years
old
so i was old enough to remember him
quite well it's taken
six years to create this extraordinary
memorial and it's the first time the
names of all the service men and women
who served under british command on
d-day and at the battle of normandy
have been brought together they will now
forever be here on gold beach
where many of the british troops arrived
77 years ago we pay
our respects to our veterans it wasn't
the grand reopening that had been
planned but where there weren't crowds
there was an intimacy a poignancy at a
ceremony curbed by covid
felt from afar by the british veterans
watching in staffordshire
like 97 year old bernard morgan who was
the youngest raf sergeant
to land in i like normandy
think that the generation you know are
thinking about these lads as well
they obviously they can't realize how
severe it was but
i'd like to think that some of the
younger generation are
you know showing an interest normandy
will forever be tied to the allied
forces
the final resting place for so many
and there will always be a draw to the
normandy beaches a place where wartime
enthusiasts
can reimagine an extraordinary battle
those who can really remember are
smaller in number now
their story though will never grow old
ali fortescue
sky news